[Music]
by we have to box
huambo elect members of european
parliament international from where are they going
to see your elect members a
european parliament in level an index with a list of
in use indicated preferred by
president of the bank mission which will
be the leader of head of  that
pan-european list
[Music]
also this project comes at an
important moment for europe after the
pandemic putin's aggression against ukraine
and the conclusion of the conference on
the future of europe europe is
already strengthening its health dimension
in the financial one  in energy
and defense our internal political cohesion
is also important at this
time the head of the list system,
if applied correctly, constitutes a
reinforcement of
europe's political leadership and its democratic legitimacy
this electoral erc bill
reinforces our political union
builds the european demos this
parliament precisely now cannot be
absent from this appointment with the  history